bon on va voir on va voir en fait si
vous êtes dans la moyenne des des
Françaises on va voir si vous êtes
casables parce que finalement c'est ça
un petit peu hein
peut-être à cause de ça on va voir mes
réponses
Julio vient nous expliquer qu'il était
pas fidèle donc je sais pas si c'est une
bonne chose de le mettre à côté d'une
jolie blonde comme Karen Mulder est très
jolie hein au lieu là je comprends qu'on
soit pas fidèle à votre place vraiment
alors très heureux de vous voir Karen
belle chantait bien
quand une fille te dise maintenant tu
sors de moi tu aimes bien ça
il sort de moi ça peut être aussi
quelque chose qui vous habite le
2 mois
alors donc tous les morceaux paroles et
musique sont de Daniel schènevez sauf un
ou les paroles sont de vous une chanson
en anglais contrairement aux autres
qui est une chanson assez dure et qui
parle un petit peu de l'expérience que
vous avez vécu ces dernières années tu
peux me traiter de folle je m'en fous je
pensais que tu étais mon ami que tu
m'aimais mais maintenant je vois le jeu
tordu que tu joues je suis fier d'être
ton ennemi c'est assez violent quand
même et si tu es chrétien tu brûlera en
enfer ce que tu m'as fait te reviendra
ça s'appelle divine justice ce morceau
hein
vous l'avez fait vous-même
je crois que ça vient venait de du fond
du cœur
j'aime croire parce que c'est vrai que
on a que à allumer la télé et pouvoir
que la justice sur terre n'existe pas
vraiment moi j'aime bien
penser que quand on fait du mal dans la
vie à un moment ou une autre ça revient
ou on le paie d'une façon ou une autre
alors cette chanson évidemment s'adresse
à tout cela à tous ceux qui vous ont
lâché à l'époque ah non mais moi la
justice divine je n'ai pas du tout écrit
ça par rapport à des gens qui ont pu
entendre mon histoire je parle de ceux
qui me l'ont fait subir c'est pas du
tout pareil
dans ce que vous disiez à l'époque il y
avait il y avait finalement des choses
qui étaient un peu délirantes et des
choses vraies également
la plupart des choses étaient vraies et
puis il y avait des choses où au moment
donné
la vérité est tellement grande que on
dit des conneries aussi mais ça
n'empêche pas que la vérité là ça
explose un peu dans la tête quand tout
d'un coup tout vous tombe dessus mais
c'est tout quoi alors vous en êtes où au
plan sentimental Caren
va parce qu'on vous voit des fois je
l'ai vu l'autre fois dans un magazine
avec un jeune homme assez simple
c'était pas vrai avec ce garçon c'était
faux non si c'était vrai mais c'est le
mois d'août
c'est une invente c'est ça c'était une
aventure du mois d'août avec Julien
c'est ça
non mais c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave
non malheureusement
une belle fille comme vous
son nombre de moches qui sont casés
bon on va voir on va voir en fait si
vous êtes dans la moyenne des Françaises
on va voir si vous êtes casables parce
que finalement c'est ça un petit peu
hein
on va essayer en tous les cas compter
sur moi pour vous aider on va faire une
interview sondage
alors
Karen dans 69% des couples c'est la
femme qui fait le ménage vous si vous
viviez avec quelqu'un ça serait qui qui
ferait le ménage
tous les deux
non parce que j'ai aucune envie de
traîner derrière lui ramasser ses
chaussettes dans 73% des couples c'est
la femme qui fait la cuisine ça serait
comment chez vous
moi je veux bien faire la cuisine s'il
fait la vaisselle
alors
38% des couples font l'amour le matin au
réveil et 73 le soir au coucher vous
soyez de quel côté vous
heureuse
et vous
oh non non
34% des femmes sont d'accord pour faire
l'amour où il veut quand il veut et vous
[Musique]
là encore si je suis amoureuse peut-être
mais quand il veut oui mais où il veut
peut-être pas ça va être gênant au
restaurant par exemple
33 % des femmes disent à leur partenaire
ce qu'elles veulent qui lui fasse c'est
ce que vous seriez dans cette
décide-moi un mouton
c'est pas moi c'est il y a 33 ans
comme ça il y a 33 % des femmes qui
disent alors mec ce qu'elles veulent
qu'il lui fasse ah d'accord oui oui
il y a 12% des femmes qui font l'amour
le premier soir
qui ne font pas le premier soir
non pas vraiment non je crois pas non
pas le premier soir quoi le deuxième
mais tu l'as déjà fait le premier soir
non mais justement je suis en train de
me poser la question mais je crois que
c'est en général quand même après
au moins une rencontre
tapotage tapotage
49% des femmes refusent de se faire
attacher et vous
quand même en France c'est pas mal il y
en a une qui est d'accord sur deux
oh c'est pas très grave
sauf si la femme demande bien sûr c'est
là on peut pas refuser là on peut pas
refuser
c'est pour faire plaisir donc on ne peut
pas les clés des menottes ça va tu as
raison 66% des femmes sont choqués par
des pratiques sadomaso
vous êtes choqués par la c'est-à-dire la
perversion à toujours
moi je trouve pas le mot
ça vous dégoûte
ça vous donne envie de gerber faire des
seins
voilà ce que je voulais dire non je
trouve ça plutôt
plutôt c'est-à-dire vraiment les trucs
sadomaso où on peut où on prend du
plaisir à faire mal à quelqu'un et ce
qui aiment souffrir la douleur je vous
dis ça me fait moi ça me fait un peu
peur des françaises qui sont choqués par
ça finalement donc vous êtes assez dans
la moyenne des Français je comprends pas
que vous arriviez pas à vous caser moi
alors les relations à trois
65% des femmes refusent les relations à
trois
j'en fais partie
alors après il y a ce qui se passe après
l'amour c'est très marrant 36 % des
Françaises se lavent 29% d'Ores 8% fume
7% boivent ou mangent 6 % recommandent
et 5% regardent la télé vous êtes dans
lequel
vous êtes dans quelle catégorie vous
une petite douche et recommence
Karen vous avez toutes les qualités
d'une voilà d'une vraie française vous
êtes complètement dans la moyenne
franchement rassurez-vous
c'est vrai que vous êtes belle
je dirais de plus en plus belle
franchement je trouve magnifique très
très bien coiffé aussi non j'ai pas mes
menottes
voilà Karen Mulder l'album s'appelle
calme Mulder et le premier single
s'appelle sors de moi et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu